what's up true believer is Walter Binet
via care and welcome to top five it's
time we cover a true legend in the comic
book industry a man who created many of
our favorite characters who are now
enjoying major success up on the big
screen that's right
today we cover the king of cameos
himself Stanley okay we heard you were
doing a top five on family cameos yeah
we want to help you out you know just
getting back together well you guys want
to help out yeah like you did in the top
five best Power Rangers episodes when I
need your help against rock yeah Eddie
you watching or what Heather hijacked my
show and did a top five worst
performances for me which you can check
out here get that out here come on man
you gotta let us help out you can do
your Stanley impression we heard it was
a really good I'm not doing my family
impression oh I think you do a hold no
wonder everybody in the family oh hey I
am NOT doing my Stanley impression
alright it's not going to happen
welcome true believers and newcomers
alike
spider-man co-creator Stanley today we
take a look at yours truly the king of
cameos specifically my very best ones so
hold on to your hats
Spidey fans excelsior that wasn't very
good nope
this is the result of a Twitter poll
that went up on awesome underscore
Walter asking you guys what the next
subject and top five should be far more
polls make sure you follow tweeters now
we all know whose family is but just in
case you don't Stan the man Lee is the
co-creator of many many heroes and
villains mostly in Marvel Comics who
have gone on to become pop-culture icon
characters like spider-man the Hulk
daredevil the x-men Doctor Strange the
Fantastic Four Iron Man and so many more
alter all their roots back to Stan for
decades now he has been a staple in
Marvel movies and TV shows
seeing him pop up on screen always
delights his fans but what are his best
appearances here are the top 5 best Stan
Lee cameo XL she'll number 5 man in
Times Square in spider-man 3 spider-man
3 might not be the best spider-man movie
or one of Stan's funnier cameos but it
does feature a moment with Stan
sincerely interacting with one of his
greatest creations the amazing
spider-man at this point in the movie
Peter is riding high everyone seems to
finally accept him a spider-man and for
the first time in his life he feels
appreciated that appreciation comes full
circle as Peter meets 'add maker for a
few quick work
you know I guess one person can make a
difference
and up step
stan is known for his funnier cameos
nowadays but I thought they had to put
this one on here for being what it was
just a very heartfelt moment in a film
overstuffed with everything under the
Sun this was already 10 years ago and
the mantle of spider-man has changed
twice since then no matter who is
dawning the red and blue type it's good
to see one of the men behind his
creation share a tender moment with him
through the magic of movies it's a good
one I felt it I felt it excelsior
number four school librarian in the
Amazing Spiderman the first amazing
spider-man movie definitely split
audiences on the handling of the
character and direction of the franchise
but there's one thing everyone can agree
on Dan's cameo was hilarious spider-man
and the lizard are fighting in Peters
high school the battle spills into the
library where we see a familiar face
blissfully unaware of all the danger
behind him as he continues to enjoy his
classical tune
[Music]
this is a fan-favorite of a lot of
people dan doesn't even have to say a
word
he's just being family and that's enough
for us whether you're a fan of the
amazing spider-man movies or not at
least you can have this to look forward
to when re watching the first movie
Dan's cameo in amazing spider-man 2 was
pretty funny as well but this is the
obvious winner of the two would you say
that cameo is amazing excelsior
number three World War two veteran in
Avengers age of Ultron this wasn't too
far of a stretch first and as he
actually was a veteran of World War two
he was in the US Army Signal Corps from
1942 to 1945 the Avengers are having a
party and anybody who's anybody is there
Iron Man war machine Black Widow
Captain America Thor and Stan Lee of
course Kat is hosting some of his World
War two buddies and the god of thunder
showing off a very special drink said
not to be for mortal men
well we all know Stan Lee is no mortal
man who's not meant for mortal men
neither was Omaha Beach blondie stop
trying to scare us all right
eggshells shield this is definitely one
of the funnier cameo stan has ever had
it was very clever to use him as a war
veteran and put him amongst the Avengers
themselves Stan showed up very briefly
towards the end of the first Avengers
movie and had a more active cameo
earlier in the film that was cut here
have a look miss Byrne come be a moron
- you must early exile - number two
rejected wedding guests in Fantastic
Four rise of the Silver Surfer why is
this one of us kamio-san has done
because he plays himself although he is
rejected from the wedding of two of his
characters thanks Fox Susan storm and
Reed Richards are getting married as
guests pour in the bouncer stops a man
claiming to be on the list when he's not
they kick him out
forgive them Stan for they know not what
they do
invitation sir I should be on that list
name Stanley yeah nice try
no really I'm Stanley well the fantastic
four movies aren't very good any of them
really this was probably the most
tolerable kicking Stan out of the
wedding was a humorous idea and having
him play himself was fun
Stan did have a cameo in the first
Fantastic Four movie from 2005 they even
gave his character a name it was okay as
far as Sam Lee cameos go welcome back to
the Baxter dr. Richards I got the usual
for you good to have you back sir thanks
really is it me or does the Human Torch
look like Captain America legs failed ah
Stanley has cameoed in over 30 projects
most of them are awesome but before
getting to number one here's a few
honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Stan Lee cameo
is and guardians of the galaxy vol 2
spoilers ahead for Marvel Studios latest
film spoilers this sort of connects all
of Stan Lee's cameos he's sitting there
in space talking to what seemed to be
the Watchers the watchers are a group of
aliens who are one of the oldest species
in the universe they record and compile
knowledge and all aspects throughout the
cosmos Stan is telling them stories of
his time on earth and seems to be boring
them since it's still in theaters we
can't show you a clip but trust me if
you haven't seen guardians too you're
missing out on more than just the best
Stan Lee cameo I remember hearing a
theory a while back about how Stan was
actually a watcher himself I'm not sure
if Marvel heard that theory and decided
to parody it or if they are really
leaning towards that to add another
dimension to Stan's cameos we know mr.
Lee has already recorded several cameos
for upcoming Marvel Studios movies so
will this watcher thing play a role in
his appearance is going forward we'll
have to see like many others I love
seeing Stan up on the big screen and
getting to be a part of these films in
any capacity has got to be a thrill for
him he's been able to stick around to
see the superhero movie bloom and the
fruits of his labor stretch well beyond
what he originally envisioned Stan is
now and will forever be the man we want
to know what you guys think what is your
favorite family cameo leave us a comment
down below and let us know you can find
me on Facebook Twitter Instagram and
snapchat you find me on twitter at pork
chop 0 to 89 you can find me on twitter
at heather ruth and instagram it easier
for more content subscribe to
youtube.com slash awesome walter like my
facebook page facebook.com slash awesome
walter B and follow me on Twitter to
take part in more polls about what may
be covered in the future
did Jim do Kerry oh uh no
[Music]
you